manchas ou pontos brancos nas unhas se
você já reparou que tem manchas ou
pontos brancos nas unhas isso pode ser
um alerta do seu corpo para uma
deficiência de zinco esse mineral é
super importante ele pode ser reposto no
nosso organismo de duas formas
diferentes com a ingestão de suplementos
ou pelo consumo de alimentos ricos nesse
mineral como é o caso dos frutos do mar
e também das sementes de abóbora que são
ótimas Fontes de zinco mas não basta só
adicionar o zinco à dieta é preciso
também evitar o consumo excessivo de
Açúcar sim pessoal o açúcar pode
interferir na absorção de zinco assim
como excesso de suplementação de cobre
tome cuidado então com açúcar e o cobro
nesse caso